[Music]
Dei is facing a major credibility crisis
brought on largely by this Harvard
president debacle because the Harvard
president the former Harvard president
was a big promoter of Dei she herself is
a Dei or Proto Dei kind of hire she had
a ridiculously pathetic academic record
she had 11 scholarly Publications she
seemed to have copied a lot of it but
even if she hadn't plagiarized much of
her publication history to have 11
Publications by the time you reach the
Pinnacle of Academia is very sad you
should have 11 academic Publications
when you're in graduate school okay
forget about throughout your faculty
career and then becoming the president
of Harvard it's pathetic and we all know
that this woman got her job because she
ticked all the politically correct boxes
and that's why it was difficult to fire
her until it wasn't until finally she
was out so a a big Dei debate has
erupted and Mark Cuban who is the
liberal owner of the Dallas Mavericks he
comes out and uh he he defends Dei so JD
Vance the conservative senator from Ohio
he says hey Mark did the Dallas
Mavericks reflect the demographics of
America as a
whole this one of the lines from the Dei
people including Mark cubin we need to
have racial quotas in our companies and
our schools and our organizations
because we need these organizations to
reflect the diversity of America and by
diversity we mean certain racial and
sexual
criteria now turns out the Dallas
Mavericks do not reflect the racial
demographics of America that reflect all
sorts of demographics of America so
Cuban responds to him and he he doesn't
actually respond to the point he doesn't
acknowledge the point he just goes on a
tie raade but the tie raade I think
undermines the whole Dei movement Mark
humanman says if you were trying to make
a stupid comment you nailed it first as
an organization as a whole yes we
do what does that mean the the
executives are white but the players are
black is that what he's saying I don't
know that that reflects very well I him
either says yes we do more importantly
though if you understand the value of
Dei it's not in checklists and quotas
it's an understanding how to best
compete as a company we hire the people
who put us in the best position to
succeed now we all know that that isn't
true Mark Cuban I think knows that that
isn't true I think he's got to be lying
here it's the most charitable read I can
have here is that he's lying he couldn't
possibly be this
stupid if it were the case that Dei
policies make companies more
competitive then why do the big activist
investor funds and the government
Regulators have to mandate the Dei
policies why do they have to Ram them
down the company's throats why do they
have to threaten the companies if the
companies don't comply with Dei why do
the investor the the activist investor
funds have to say we're going to pull
our money out of your company we're
going to tank your stock price if you
don't comply with Dei if Dei is so good
for the
company that doesn't seem to make a lot
of sense if if Dei policy is just
naturally made a company better the
companies would eagerly adopt
them it it it's the same error that you
see when feminist activists say that
women make 75 cents on the dollar that
that men do and we just know that isn't
true that might literally be true in
that
women leave the workforce to become
mothers in that women are less
aggressive about negotiating raises in
that women work shorter hours as as a
whole in that's true men and women are
different they behave differently so
maybe ultimately they get paid
differently but the the feminist claim
that women make 75 cents on the dollar
for doing the exact same work as men
that's obviously ridiculous if that were
the case companies would only hire women
you think companies hate women or
something you think you think you tell a
Fortune 500 company hey you can save
25% of your labor costs if you hire
women but Rich uncle pennybags in the
sea Suite says no I hate those women you
kidding me I'm not letting some skirt in
here no way I don't pay I don't care if
we have to pay 200% more for our labor
costs I just hate those bras those
ladies I don't think so I think they
would hire the women in two
seconds but it's just not true and the
Dei thing is not true and it's very
clear de is being exposed here Dei
policies prioritize leftist social
engineering
over competitiveness over productivity o
but and over this is the important part
over fairness we all know that this is
so deeply
unfair most people have been raised to
believe that racial discrimination that
that being told you can't do something
you can't get a job you can't go to a
certain school because of the color of
your skin that that is unfair and ugly
and not nice and what Dei does is
exactly that says oh yeah you're a
little too pale sorry no job sorry no
admission to schools yeah Oh no you're a
little too straight if you if you gay if
you g yourself up a little bit then
maybe we'll consider you but n you
straight guy h no you're a Christian nah
not going to work sorry we all know
that's unfair and so the best defenses
they have are the bloviations of a guy
like Mark Cuban which is not not very
persuasive my best friend has a
doctorate in English and spent much of
his education studying feminism and
gender Theory so he maintains that
gender is a purely social construct that
is in no way informed by biological sex
I attempted to argue the idea that a
majority of men or women would inform
the idea of the genders at a base level
and he denied that stating that there is
no individual aspect of either
masculinity or femininity that holds up
under concentrated scrutiny for example
women women are more likely to desire to
be the primary child care provider is
not something he'd agree with because
he'd say that there's no objective way
to prove that this is true from a
biological standpoint as opposed to
cultural influence just because a
majority conforms to those
characteristics or believes they exist
doesn't mean that they are rooted in
reality he points to supposedly
gender-based Concepts throughout history
that have been proven false like the
belief that women are less intelligent
than men as evidence that my
argumentation methodology is flawed and
that because it's based in the concept
of the majority it doesn't hold up to
his
counterarguments I know that he would
welcome a compelling and intellectually
sound
rebuttal your your friend seems rather
confused he he says that you can't prove
that women are more likely to desire a
certain thing but of course you can
prove that you would just take a public
opinion poll hey women are you more
likely than men to desire to be mothers
obviously the vast majority of women
would say yes yes so that proves it he
says well there's no scientific way to
prove what are you talking about scient
what's the what's the scientific way to
prove desire you ask somebody and they
describe their will and their desire to
you and then you have your
answer well uh okay but they shouldn't
desire that that's the next question
right well there's nothing natural about
that desire well I don't know most women
for all of history have desired that so
is there not something natural about
that more to the point is there not
something natural about culture are
these things totally divorced one from
the other your friend brings up this
argument he says for a lot of history
people thought women were stupider than
men women are different from men women's
Brains work differently from Men Women
reason in a different way than men do
Larry Summers got fired from Harvard
another president of Harvard who got
fired he was pushed out of the Harvard
presidency for making this point in 2006
he just pointed at a chart and said that
the IQ Bel bell curve for men and women
are different and for for men it's just
it's wider so he said at the high at the
absolute highest levels of intelligence
levels much higher than the IQs of me or
anyone else that we're talking about
today the very very highest IQ people on
earth almost certainly to be men and the
dumbest people on earth almost certainly
to be certain to be men because the the
bell curve is just wider and some
evidence for this would be that no woman
had ever won the fields prize the fields
medal which is the highest uh award in
mathematics until this became a big
controversy and then something like 10
years after that a woman finally won the
the fields medal but that that would be
it because women have won all sorts of
prizes and done all sorts of great
scholarly work I'm not denying any of
that but at the very very very highest
outlier Peak there are some differences
yeah so it's Politically Incorrect to
say but you know if your budd's so
obsessed with science you know I suppose
one would want to fire follow the
science though when you do follow the
science and you get fired from Harvard
if you're Larry Summers other people get
fired from Harvard for other reasons I I
guess what I would ask your friend
is where does culture come from where
does Society come from why do we do the
things that we do that are socially
constructed do those social
constructions have any basis in reality
in in physical reality
even do physical things imp metaphysical
things is this leftist tears tumbler can
we deduce from the physical
characteristics of the leftist tis
Tumblr that it is good for certain
things and bad for other things that
it's better for some things than for
other things can we deduce just looking
at the Tumblr that the Tumblr is better
for bringing leftist tears into my mouth
than it is for playing
guitar we can do that okay
can we not say the same thing about
people and our roles in society I think
we probably can man what a great clip
that was now hold up ring that Bell
subscribe to the Michael nolles YouTube
channel see you next time